hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime uproar and the direct
sequel to the seven deadly sins manga
called the four knights of the
apocalypse just got absolutely crazy all
four knights of apocalypse are finally
together in one place a new race called
nephilim has just been confirmed in the
seven deadly sins world and if that
wasn't enough former members of the ten
commandments have been resurrected as
servants of chaos and are attempting to
destroy leonis this manga is on fire
right now people need to stop sleeping
on it so let's get into it you guys know
the drill if you enjoy our vids and you
want to see more in the future leave a
quick like and comment it really helps
with that youtube algorithm and it only
takes you like a second and of course
subscribing and hitting that bell is a
very real way of directly supporting the
channel and it's completely free you can
also hit me up on twitter and instagram
at animeopror finally this video will
contain four nights of apocalypse manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned okay so with all
four nights of the apocalypse finally
being revealed and with all of them
gathered together in one place the manga
seems to have really reached a new more
intense phase just when it seemed like
things might calm down a bit after the
crazy reveal of gawain and the return of
sunshine things definitely did not calm
down and in fact they got way wilder
fully aware of what's been happening in
leonis king arthur decided to use the
power of chaos to revive galand and
molaskula two former members of the ten
commandments as servants of chaos chaos
kaland and chaos mulaskula their mission
is to destroy the remnants of the seven
deadly sins and the four knights of the
apocalypse and they begin wrecking havoc
all over leonis
working on direct orders from king
arthur they begin killing the non-humans
who live in the onus along with any
humans who directly serve the seven
deadly sins and the four knights of the
apocalypse such as the holy knights
worse yet meliodas and gill thunder
quickly realized that galland and
melascula are just diversions arthur
wants meliotis and the others to focus
on fighting these two former
commandments while someone else captures
former king bhartra the man who has the
power of vision the power of prophecy
bhartra's visions give leonis a tactical
advantage over camelot and arthur is
planning to put a stop to that right now
and so meliotis is forced to rush and
protect bartra and the fight against
galand and mulaskula is left up to the
holy knights and the four knights of
apocalypse however as we know the four
knights only just assembled for the
first time and percival tristan and
gawain barely even know each other and
yet they will now be forced to fight two
elite demon warriors infused with the
terrifying power of chaos
man nakaba really knows how to raise the
tension in a story in an instant as
galland and melascula prepare to cause
more chaos and leonis while waiting for
the seven deadly sins to arrive and
fight them tristan gawain and percival
suddenly appear in front of them thanks
to gawain's teleportation magic gallant
and malascala are immediately able to
identify that gawain possesses sunshine
and that tristan is the son of meliotis
and elizabeth then lancelot shows up and
the commandments recognize him as the
son of bonn and elaine the four knights
of apocalypse proceed to officially
introduce themselves as the four knights
of the apocalypse for the first time and
an epic battle commences
galland rushes the four knights and then
melascula attempts to trap tristan in a
spell called cage of darkness a spell
whose appearance seems to be a direct
reference to the ballads from berserk
mulaskula thinks that this is enough to
defeat tristan thanks to the fact that
her demon magic has been infused with
chaos power she thinks that she will be
able to consume his soul in only 30
minutes but only like a minute or two
after he is trapped tristan breaks out
of the cage of darkness using the power
of goddess magic meanwhile galand is
duking it out with gawain as lancelot
and percival prepared to make their own
mark on the fight up to this point
percival was getting his power mainly
from his friends and party members donny
nussiens and anne but now that he is
allied with the other knights of the
apocalypse and with the holy knights of
leonis against these two chaos demons he
can feel that his new allies are giving
him additional power given the nature of
percival's hope magic this is of course
a big deal galland becomes fixated on
taking out gawain because her magic
smells the same as eskenor's magic
galland of course still bears a huge
grudge against eskanor who not only
defeated him but also humiliated him in
the original 7 deadly sins story since
gawain's strength still can't compare to
escondors galland manages to smash her
into the ground and it looks like he is
about to destroy her but then he begins
second-guessing himself internally his
grudge against eskanor reminded him that
he was once a member of the ten
commandments who served the demon king
even though his current mental
conditioning is telling him that he is
an apostle of chaos who serves the king
of chaos this internal conflict leads
lancelot to realize that galland and
malaskula have been brainwashed and are
being manipulated by king arthur gawain
then gets back to her feet and
demonstrates another one of her
abilities not only is she able to use
teleportation magic on herself and other
people but she can also use it on
objects and she uses it to teleport her
own sword right into galan's abdomen a
shocked galand realizes that someone who
has such advanced offensive spells can't
be an ordinary warrior and this seems to
give further support to the theory that
gawain received special magical training
from an incredibly powerful wizard
possibly even merlin herself gawain
proceeds to nearly cut galland in half
but even that isn't enough to destroy
him however that is when one of
percival's chibi clones shows up enters
galand's body as he is putting it back
together and detonates causing a massive
explosion that completely destroys gland
or at least that's what it looks like
for the moment seriously is there
anything that hope magic can't do this
is just such a crazy versatile ability
anyway with galande out of the way the
focus shifts back to the fight between
tristan and molascula and that is when
we get the big reveal about tristan's
true power and true race during the
battle melascula summons some sort of
creepy monster that seems to be an
artificial fusion of demon clan and
goddess clan souls there is a humanoid
face that is attached to the monster and
it kind of looks like ludo shell but
this entire thing is just a creepy mess
at any rate this monster is resistant to
both goddess and demon attacks and
tristan's attempt to take it out using
ark ends up being completely ineffective
malasula then calls tristan a nephilim
the impure child of a demon and a
goddess mulaskula begins mocking tristan
for his lack of strength in comparison
to his legendary parents but this
doesn't seem to bother tristan at all
and in fact tristan is so giddy and
almost friendly during the battle that
melascula actually becomes annoyed with
him a random fairy then shows up and
interrupts the fight this fairy asks
where the third member of malacca's
party went after their arrival at leonis
but instead of answering malaskula
slices the fairy into pieces
nevertheless when the question was asked
melascula did think to herself that the
other member of the party who appears to
be the knight with the star-shaped visor
that lancelot is searching for was
heading somewhere near the castle that
is enough information for the fairy who
turns out to be lancelot in disguise
since lancelot possesses the power of
heart reading he could read malasula's
thoughts and he concludes that the
knight with the star-shaped visor must
be going to the dungeons lancelot then
transforms into his normal form and
begins manipulating velasco's mind by
reminding her that she is really a demon
a former member of the ten commandments
this triggers a similar reaction in
malascula as it did in galande as the
brainwashing spell that has been placed
on her begins to clash with her true
memories this internal struggle
ultimately forces malasula to transform
into her giant snake 4 which of course
puts the entire capital of leonis in
immediate danger because of the sheer
size and power of this giant form and
that is when tristan decides to get
serious
a demon mark manifests on his forehead
his eyes turn black and before melascula
can even react tristan turns her entire
body into swiss cheese everyone is
shocked by tristan's new form and power
and the collapsing melascula concludes
that despite appearing to be more like
his mother on the outside the hidden
darkness within tristan makes him a
monster just like his father now back in
his normal form tristan says that he had
been holding off on using that power
because of such comments but he must
have concluded that velascula's giant
snake form was just too dangerous for
the people of leonis so he did what he
had to do and quickly send her packing
again he sent her packing for now but it
seems that king arthur still has some
tricks in store for the four nights of
apocalypse we will learn more about that
in the coming chapters but we need to
talk about the massive reveals about
tristan and the nephilim in chapter 68.
tristan's race is now officially
classified as nephilim and he is the
only known character in both the
original series and the sequel who is a
natural-born nephilim we have seen other
instances of someone using both demon
and goddess magic like for example mael
slash esterosa and melasculus creepy
monster thing that was created from
demon and goddess souls but tristan is
the only true nephilim from birth this
means that he will have unique powers
and abilities that no other character
possesses this includes using both
goddess and demon magic which he can
already do but this will also likely
include overpowered fusions of these two
types of magic the likes of which we
have never seen before i am extremely
excited to see what the story does with
this brand new race and i wonder if
there are other nephilim out there that
we just haven't met yet in our own world
the nephilim are a thing but they have
historically been described in many
different ways depending on the source
and the mythological tradition that you
look at in some sources they are
described as giants in others they are
fallen angels in others still they are
angel human hybrids and finally in some
sources they are angel demon hybrids as
is the case with tristan actually
tristan's case is extra interesting
because his father is a demon and his
mother is a goddess in a human body so
technically tristan has goddess demon
and human properties and that human
aspect could prove to be more important
than we realize because of the unique
connection between humans and chaos
power the introduction of the nephilim
race is definitely a big deal for the
world of the seven deadly sins but at
the same time it feels like an organic
and perfectly logical addition to that
world and that is why i personally love
it honestly i think that all four
knights of the apocalypse have extremely
cool powers and abilities and i can't
wait to find out more about all of them
do you guys agree and did you like the
addition of the nephilim race
also what unique powers and abilities do
you think that the nephilim possess
compared to the other races finally how
strong do you think that tristan and
lancelot actually are at this point in
the story from what we've seen so far i
feel like percival and gawain have
amazing powers but are still beginners
when it comes to being knights but
tristan and lancelot seem to have a lot
more experience so to me it feels like
they are in a class above the other two
what do you guys think let me know down
below if you guys enjoyed this video and
you want to see more four nights of
apocalypse content right here on the
channel leave a quick like and comment
right now it helps me out a lot and
don't forget to subscribe hit that
notification bell and select the option
that says all it is a completely free
but direct and important way of
supporting the channel you can also hit
me up on twitter and instagram at
opera i want to give a big thank you to
all of our anime outpour patrons for
making videos like this one possible
special thank you to kyle salisbury this
man is an absolute mad lad and a
disciple of lord twego himself and i
can't forget all of our the one tier
patrons the ones who rise above all
other clans including alpha sigma pate
heffa the red-haired fox hinokami and
water the toasted chi corey mcgowan the
fallen chosen orihime wukong dante
tinnell and big buddhist finally thank
you also to our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
angel cruz alicia octor bunny parks fat
boy games kaido might be a duck alivania
and anime s codem if you guys enjoy our
videos and you feel that they provide
value to you consider supporting us on
patreon as always thank you guys so much
for watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys